der soundtrack der schweiz vor 100
jahren unvorstellbar damals was seither
an geräuschen alles dazu gekommen ist
fortlaufend haben sich den menschen neue
töne aufgedrängt und eingelegt
für diese klangwelten der brocken
interessieren sich jetzt junge
historiker der sammelband sound der zeit
vereint diverse studien zur sound
history auch von jan friedrich mißfelder
einfach herausarbeiten wie menschen
früher ihre welt umwelt mit den ohren
wahrgenommen haben welche bedeutung sie
den gegeben haben was sie als lärm
begriffen haben was sie aber auch als
angenehme klänge begriffen haben und
erschließt damit eine ganze neue welt
historische erfahrung
sound history am beispiel von glocken
wie hier in der zürcher st peter kirche
sie waren die ersten waren und
alarmanlagen der stadt
jahrhundertelang haus den der turmspitze
rund um die uhr ein brand wächter im
notfall hatte er signalhörner zu blasen
und mit den glocken alarm zu schlagen
die glocken waren in früheren epochen
das massen kommunikationsmittel sowohl
des staates als auch der kirche sie
zeigten anfangs feuersbrünste gab in den
städten sie zeigten an wann im
kriegsfall die menschen gewarnt werden
sollten aber sie zeigten auch
alltägliche ereignisse wie beerdigungen
oder geburten an
damals hat sich niemand antun der
glocken gestört vielmehr waren sie
absolut lebensnotwendig zur orientierung
der menschen in ihrer welt
was einst unbestritten heimatliche
klänge waren hat sich für viele leute
zum störgeräusch gewandelt die
brandwache von sankt peter ist die
museum der feuerwehr nachgestellt hier
sind auch ihre alarmierungs mit
dokumentiert
bis ins frühe 20 jahrhundert waren es
ausschließlich manuelle instrumente
zum instrumentarium gehörten lange auch
glocken
doch der verkehr nahm rasant zu
produzierte gewaltigen lernen und
erforderte laut alarmsignal
erst mit dem zweiklang horn aus dem
kompressor konnte man sich wieder gehör
verschaffen in der städtischen
kakophonie die gesamte akustische
wahrnehmung wandelte sich radikal
die geräusche der industrie des verkehrs
von motoren von maschinen waren über
lange zeit nach der industrialisierung
vor allen dingen ein zeichen für
fortschritt und war quasi stolz darauf
dass es in der stadt laut war weil das
zeigte an dass etwas gegen das
wirtschaftlich die stadt prosperierte
oder das land im laufe der zeit gibt es
in den großen städten die ersten
initiativen gegen diesen lärm und
heutzutage möchte man industrielärm
verkehrslärm so leise wie möglich
gestalten damit man in den städten
wieder so viel ruhe wie nur
irgendmöglich hat doch wenn der gewohnte
leben fehlt wird anderes hörbar und das
kann genauso beunruhigend sein